from the new york post abercrombie
deletes ad after tweet storm over
normalizing obesity
i saw this
this image and uh you know i want to
start out by saying i'm not trying to be
mean to this woman i don't know who she
is but i want to say one thing
will the new york post not let us
actually get the image in there uh she
needs help
she needs serious help and i'm not
saying to be mean i'm not trying to be
disrespectful this woman her life is in
danger yeah her pants are being used as
a hammock for her stomach i am not
trying to be mean or disrespectful this
is no way intend to do that it's to make
a point
i'm sure she's a nice person but she is
suffering from morbid or moribund
obesity
it's it's a large a principal cause of
cancer precursor to cancer your heart
will fail you will die
people are making this into a a job
they're rewarding it and when i see this
it's just one component of what i see as
you call it cultural decay in the united
states i'm going to call it outright
societal collapse
if we normalize
morbid and more abundant obesity
in how many generations do we have one
two when our population is collapsing
and unable to sustain itself so
abercrombie i would say in in in a case
for optimism deleted the ad
but there was that famous story in
london it was in the uk i think it was
where they had this ad as beachbody
ready do you guys remember this and it
was a thin woman in a bikini and then
all of these fat activists got angry and
said it was fat phobic or shaming so
they replaced it with like a similar ad
of morbidly and more abundantly obese
women
i'm just saying when i see this stuff
you talk about the cult fat phobia and
all these other phobias it is leading in
one direction and it is societal
collapse and i'm not talking about
oh no you know if if two men get married
settle collapse no i'm totally fine with
gay marriage that's that's fine actually
i think marriage is a good institution
and they're you know i'm sure the
conservatives have their arguments
against it or whatever but i don't think
that will destroy society what i think
will destroy society is when outside of
that you tolerate the targeting of
children outside of that you actually
tell people that they can be more
abundantly obese and it is marketable
and we will pay you to do it and it's
like when your society starts telling
you that
it's falling down but that's like real
compassion right like you're looking at
this woman and saying you're not living
a good quality of life i want something
better for you and i think it ties into
this this bigger idea in our society of
like tolerance right if if you don't
tolerate everything then you're bigoted
or you're hateful but it's like no i
actually have my ideas that are rooted
in something
and you know british journalist douglas
murray talks about this he calls this
year zero
that today you know we think that we are
smarter and we know more than everybody
that came before us
and none of your ideas are rooted in
anything
and that's dangerous because if it's not
rooted in anything then the people that
come after you can also uproot whatever
you've just built
and so it's it's not compassionate to
have to glorify this right it's not
compassionate to let a 10 year old
decide what gender they are
because we have things that we look to
our past and say well this isn't right
well we need to fix this
but but we're being sold on this fake
idea of tolerance this this fake idea of
compassion and it's leading our society
to complete the evil it is 100 it is
evil in my opinion to go to someone like
i make the joke when i we got these
cookies they are oreo cookies
with birthday cake filling dipped in
fudge
covered in sprinkles with a sugar
printed image that says step on snack
and find out on top
and the joke is when i hand it to people
i say it's evil to do this
it is because these things are extremely
bad for you but the reality is like
in saying that we you're it's a warning
basically like i always tell people like
dude one cookies 130 calories and like
18 to 20 carbs that's addictive and it's
an addictive but here you have people
who
they go to these people and they tell
them
eat a pint of ben and jerry's all to
yourself it's fine you should be you
shouldn't be ashamed of who you are
that's like giving someone poison and a
dick
trying to addict them to something and
then like you're not helping them like
i'm sure opiates feel good we aren't
happy that doctors are over prescribing
them you're not helping someone by
getting them addicted to these drugs i
feel the same way about so much in this
in the society the reality is hard work
is a better gift this is the challenge
if your message is work hard work out
and you will feel better than ever
but people are like in the short term it
sucks it hurts
then the other people come by and say
here's a glazed donut with a double
cheeseburger a luther burger and it will
taste good right now
what they're not telling you is that you
will suffer for this curse and they're
telling you they're the good guys doing
it we want people to roll up their
sleeves and work hard and they will feel
better they will be happier they will
clear their minds
and that's and that's that's the hard
message
so telling people work hard pay back
your loans if you took a loan out well
that's like that's so mean no no free
ride free ride
nothing good comes easy man and you know
i think it's all tied together the
tolerance the convenience right all
these people that they have amazon the
big flat screen tv smoking pot eating
their glazed donuts like are they happy
they were told that they would be happy
but they're not they're sad they're
empty they're fat and so i mean we have
to pick out things in our society that
we need to be intolerant of right not
not in the sense that we should hate
people like i don't hate her like you
just said but we need to to decide what
is right what makes us happy what is
actually good
um but i you know it's this scare tactic
that if you oppose anything then you're
bigoted then you're hateful right i'm
not tolerant of murderers
i'm not tolerant of of a parents drew
that that take their kids to drag shows
and we need to be we need to draw the
lines somewhere and they're erasing
every line everywhere but it's it's it's
this idea you know so i was driving in
the car and that song by taylor taylor
swift came out came on what is it called
um
you need to calm down love t swift t
swift yeah the song is
like it's a little bit about cancel
culture and the second verse is about
homophobes and transphobes and all that
stuff
and it's like
it's it's
this idea
that people only criticize
another a behavior because they hate a
person
is just wrong but here's the funny thing
when i hear that and she's singing the
song and she's like you need to stop
just talking about all the reasons you
hate this person and i'm like you know
the conversations we have here with
people who are concerned about like drag
shows for children they're not saying
that it's just because they hate someone
they're not looking at the person and
being like oh i just hate them they're
saying hey what are you doing to those
kids it's about an action and towards
kids for the most part they're they're i
i've uh i was at an event in the uk and
there was a drag queen on stage or
whatever one going after kids nobody
cared i've been at trump events where
there have been transgender trump
supporters nobody cared they don't hate
them they hate the actions when you
target and do like a child and do
something corrupt in this instance with
the abercrombie and fitch it's just a
long line and a big story about getting
people to gorge themselves until they're
in serious jeopardy that is not
compassion well this goes back to what i
was saying is these people hate you
right like if if i'm sitting here
telling you
it's okay to be unhealthy
keep being unhealthy
see how that goes for you you should be
as unhealthy
as physically possible that's not a
statement of care that's a statement of
hate that's the real hate right if i
come out and say you know what it's fine
mutilate the genitals of your children
that is going to go so well for them
that is going to make them so happy in
the future even though they have no idea
why they're doing what they're doing
keep doing that it's going to go so well
in the future it's a statement of hate
that means you hate somebody but but
maybe they hate you maybe they they
they want there to be less people but
when i look at a lot of this
i look at a message that says
in the what is the end result of all of
the things they're saying from you know
we're talking about the morbid obesity
being normalized to the um you know just
the abortion of the point of birth
the end result of this whether it's
intentional or not will be less people
pain and suffering and death and then
people being unable to reproduce and
then people not having kids
so i look at that and i'm like i'm not
saying anyone who's pushing for fat
acceptance or whatever is trying to
reduce population i'm saying the end
result will be regardless of what you
want less people now china's not doing
this in fact they're doing the opposite
they're not letting these messages
persist on tick tock in china but in the
u.s they are so what's going to happen
the u.s is crumbling china is also
having their own economic problems but
in the social ways they're rejecting it
they're doing these ads like to promote
masculinity and stuff like that
meanwhile they're using their app in the
us to push wokeness
uh
what happened exactly tick-tock
tick-tock that's bite dance a chinese
company
and spying on people you talk about
compassion i'm thinking about like
raising a kid and a kid that like maybe
the kid goes and steals something from
the store and comes home what's the
compassionate thing to do it's okay
don't worry about it i love you anyway
that's not i don't think that's
compassion it's that kid you lose your
privileges you return that you apologize
you cry about it you feel horrible about
it you you feel
you know
you feel humiliated then you come home
and you you lose electricity in your
bedroom now we're shutting off the
breaker you're in your room
you cannot stay over your friend's house
on the weekends you have to be home at 5
p.m every day until for three months
like that's maybe hardcore but that will
teach the kid don't steal do not destroy
society that i think is compassion as
horrible and as hard as it is to do that
to a kid
like you're guiding these wild animals
like what you don't you know is it
compassionate to shear the sheep yet we
do it anyway i don't know actually it is
the sheep like it yeah they do well i'll
tell you here i'm screaming when their
legs are tied up it's another another
question well you know there's some
things we do to farm animals they don't
like yeah that's what's insemination
i'll make like the the religious okay
the religious analogy or the christian
analogy of you know when god punishes
you or when you sin
um and drew i don't know about you but
like you know we have a set of rules
right we have a set of ideologies that
that we are rooted in and you may
disagree with the ideology with religion
but when we sin we're told you have to
atone for these sins you have to confess
and don't you always feel great when you
confess and you say i did this wrong let
me let me try to have some forgiveness
and that's like coming from god right
and it's the same thing with kids that
you have somebody over you telling you
this is right and this is wrong and
that's why i think maybe some of these
people hate you hate us but i don't
think everybody does i think it really
is
rooted in a lack of ideas right they
don't have roots in anything and it's
running amok i mean we're seeing it in
real time because they've been convinced
that liberalism right
they've been convinced that liberalism
means just all hands are off
you can't have a functioning society
without
any kind of rule of law because then you
run into stuff like this if we're just
void
of rule of law in a society then
the
the the the
the sexualizing of kids is okay in a
society like that
because you can who the hell are you to
say anything you're a fascist you're
telling me that i can't touch your kid
you're a fascist that's where these
people's minds are there has to be some
kind of moral code in society or as the
society cannot function there is no more
like the moral code has been destroyed
and you know with with the with the drag
kid stuff you know people say well their
parents they can decide what they want
their kid to do
but why is it not okay for a parent to
give their bottle to give their kid a
bottle of jack and say well it's my kid
i can allow him to drink well they say
that's harmful to them it's physically
harmful and you cannot do that that's a
value societal standard that we've set
it's culture and values why are we not
allowed to set societal standards when
it comes to morality right like 50 years
ago if you taught the communist
manifesto
in school you'd probably get fired as a
teacher but now you can teach kids about
sexuality you know they have these
transition closets
why can't why are we not like where is
it going why is there no structure at
all there is a rejection of that there's
been a rejection of that but there is a
very deep-seated cult that is trying
very very hard to maintain these things
like wokeness in this country
is not
that prominent but they are influential
because they've seated themselves in our
institutions
so what's happening now is
we i hear it
in every facet there are there's police
officers who are like oh i don't want to
say too much because i lose my job there
are fbi agents who are like if i speak
out or lose my job and then what happens
the cult and the establishment get to do
whatever they want because the people
who know what's going on are too scared
to speak up and it's really frustrating
and that is a major black pill now when
you look at at least the elections over
the past you know few months major white
pill when you take a look at abercrombie
pulling that ad i'd say it's a white
pill yeah i'm feeling rather optimistic
but it is really frustrating every day
when it's just like
people are are too scared to actually
just say no yeah after 2001 and 9 11 um
the patriot act got signed and i feel
like it bred a generation of psychopaths
no offense if you were raised in this
situation you just don't know that what
you that your lack of understanding
about the danger of the patriot act is
if you don't realize that the patriot
act is a complete subversion of
everything that the united states
constitution was meant to stand for then
you've been you've fallen for this lack
of morality and then i went through a
phase where i was like well if we're
doing evil around the world if we're
invading and conquering iraq for weapons
of mass destruction that didn't actually
exist then how can i criticize the
chinese government for having people in
camps i don't have a moral authority to
do that so i actually went through a
phase where i was like i can't be a
moral arbiter anymore because the united
states is doing such evil things but i
realize like just because the united
states of the patriot act is evil i i
think it's an evil act uh doesn't mean
that we can't stand up for what's right
when we know it's right or if we believe
it's right we still have an opportunity
and
we have a responsibility to do if we
don't do it who's no one will not only
should you but you have to thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you